[Music]
foreign
and we'd like to share with you our top
three reasons why we think you should
attend our workshop at positcom this
year
tiny noodles is a framework for modeling
using tinyverse principles so it's built
to make your modeling practice ergonomic
effective and safe
play economic we mean that if you're a
tiny versus user tidy models code will
feel expressive and fluent to you
as for Effectiveness tidy models equips
you to build performant models quickly
and once you've got the basics put
highly Advanced tools at your fingertips
lastly Titan models is safe in that we
built a packages to protect here at its
time and failures
models typically depth such as
overfitting and data retention tiny
models is stable and production ready so
now is a good time to learn it secondly
the instructs US Hannah Simon and I are
programmers and we worked on the Tidy
models packages full-time but we're also
Educators and we teach studying models
regularly
so that means the material and the code
in there has been through several
cohorts of Workshop attendees in their
feedback so when we say tiny models are
stable we also mean the interface and
the way we teach it is
the third reason is the level of the
workshop this year we are offering both
an introductory tidy models Workshop
this one and an advanced one taught by
Max so that means this one will be
a true beginners Workshop
already used tidy models particularly in
this one
or if you want to learn all things tidy
models take this one and take the
advanced one the next day so if you'd
like to join us in Chicago please go to
posit.com and we hope to see you